Omega Lull, Hyper Poggers, so, gleich da, Text kann weg, weil ich bin ja gleich da, Instant Vagban, so, erstmal Settings einstellen,
irgendwie hat es das jetzt beim Account wechseln komplett, äh, wieder zurückgesetzt, was natürlich auch ziemlich, ziemlich räudig ist, irgendwie, ne,
so, Scope Sensitivity hat es irgendwie auf 0,5, Maus Sensitivity hat es, glaube ich, auf 9, übrigens, das Menü ist übrigens von Overwatch kopiert,
das sieht 1 zu 1 so aus, wie Overwatch das Menü, aber ich meine, das ist ja auch Paladins Royale, das merkt man, die haben gedacht,
hey, wir haben uns jetzt bei Overwatch hinten dran gehängt mit dem Game, also können wir uns auch bei Fortnite hinten dran hängen mit dem Game,
und davon abgesehen, dass es das einzige Battle Royale Game ist bisher, was mir Bock macht,
das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, ehrlich gesagt, Hyper Poggers, Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, so, und hier muss ich die Musik ausmachen,
weil sonst sackt das, Alter, sackt das, warum mir Fortnite, weil ich das Bauen in Fortnite nicht mag, ich weiß, das ist im Prinzip genau das,
was Fortnite ausmacht, aber irgendwie, irgendwie macht es mir keinen Bock, Lull, Alter, ich versuche jetzt mal, das, das Meme Tool zu starten,
in der Hoffnung, ich habe keine doppelten, ach, nee, das geht nicht, ha, da muss ich umstellen, oh, Moment, die Katz will raus, die Katz will raus, Alter,
die Katz, ja, ja, ich lasse dich raus, ist gut, ist gut, Katz, ich lasse dich raus, ja, ja, die Katz ist immer geil, ne, wenn du, die Katz stellt sich vor die Tür,
Mäu, Mäu, Mäu, Mäu, machst du die Tür auf, nee, ich gehe jetzt nicht raus, das ist jetzt, jetzt habe ich keinen Bock, rauszugehen, geht Schreck, Noob,
hast du keine Katzenklappe, doch, aber es geht hier um, ja, mein Arbeitszimmer, da habe ich keine Katzenklappe in der Tür,
die lag hier hinter mir auf dem Sofa, so, ich muss jetzt mal Musik ausmachen, dass ich was höre, weil das Game, wow, MonkaS,
das Game ist Sound Whoring Deluxe, sage ich euch, jetzt geht jetzt der Sound wieder kaputt, das passiert in dem Game irgendwie manchmal,
bisschen leise, oder, oder, bisschen leise, bisschen lauter mache, ja,
ich muss nämlich was hören, sonst hört man nichts, Sensitiv, Moment, irgendwie stimmt meine Sense nicht, was ist, was ist da los,
wie kommt es, dass du das Game spielst, ja, ich muss ja irgendwas mal spielen, ja, es gibt ja irgendwie nichts, was mir gefällt,
und es gibt vor allem kein Battle Royale Game, was mir gefällt, außer das, das finde ich ganz gut, äh, Controls,
wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt auch nicht der Ultra-Profi oder so, ich spiele das jetzt ja nicht so lang, nee, da, da, Fabian spielt das nicht,
der Fabian hat keinen Bock auf so einen Scheiß,
so, springen wir da mal ab, da geht, also, wenn man hier abspringt, ist immer das Beste, dann ist man entweder Instant Down,
oder man schreckt was, auf, gib Gas, Battlefield 5 Battle Royale, ja, oh, ja, ich kann's, ich kann's ja kaum erwarten, ey,
ich kann's kaum erwarten, ja, ich sag gleich was zu dem Game, ich muss mir das mal kurz einspielen, bisschen,
siehste, das war schon die übelste Fail-Landung, irgendwie ist keiner hier gelandet, ich weiß auch nicht, warum,
Ich muss lauter machen
Leute sagt mir immer wie der Sound ist
Ich muss glaube ich lauter machen
Weil ich höre die Gegner nicht richtig
Schwerter ist der größte Crap in dem Game
Was war denn das da hinten
Ich habe da hinten was gehört
Moment Leute
Ich muss kurz raus tippen
Ich muss ein Ticken lauter machen
Ich höre nichts
So
Perfekt
Jetzt höre ich was
Und wie sich das natürlich gehört
Erstmal bei so Games
Komplett alles ausschalten
Meine Waffen sind übrigens scheiße
Und hier ist einer
Ich muss gucken
Dass ich irgendwie eine gescheite Waffe kriege
Sonst ist Instant Rip angesagt
Okay
Ein paar Tränke sind nicht verkehrt
Alter es leckt
Es leckt
Habt ihr es?
Warte mal
Oh ich höre was
Oh der hat noch eine beschissenere Waffe
Als ich
Der Typ
Gut
Nice
Okay das suckt
Meine Waffe ist übelst der Rotz
Und da drüben ist noch ein anderer
Oh fuck
See you
Ich bin weg hier
Jetzt Sandwichen wir ihn
Schreckt
Alter
Sag mal
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ey
Sandwich
Sandwich Alter
Was soll
Alter
Was
Ja out mich please
Okay dann nicht
Ich bin weg
Die sollen sich selbst bewegen
In 8 Minuten werde ich wiederblebt
In 8 Sekunden
Ja findet mich nicht Leute
Findet mich nicht
Blitz
Null
Nix wie weg
Das war
Das war Hyper MonkaS gerade
Und ich hab
Übelste Rotzwaffen
Konnt weder was looten
Noch sonst was
Ich glaub die Runde
Das wird nix
MonkaGiga war das
Das war nicht MonkaS
MonkaMega
Haben die sich jetzt eigentlich gekillt da oben?
Oder steht das?
Die Stelzen
Die Stelzen sich immer noch reinhaben
Fuck fuck
Nicht Amor
Ich hab keine Waffe
Ach fuck Alter
Scheiße
Okay
Ich hab ja nix ey
Naja
Oh
Das hat echt jetzt
Guck mal wir sind ein
Wir haben uns so lang rumgedrückt
Dass die Hälfte der Leute verreckt ist ey
Hier
Guck mal
Silver Noob
So
Ähm
Warte mal
Ich wollte doch jetzt irgendwas machen
Was hab ich vergessen
Ähm
Irgendwas hab ich auch gesagt
Was ich machen muss
Ähm
Ha
Weiß nicht
Wollte ich die Musik anmachen oder so?
Ist die Lautstärke eigentlich in Ordnung gewesen?
In Game?
Hat das gepasst?
Ich muss halt den Soundtrack von dem Game aus machen
Lautstärke war gut
Okay
Ja
Ich muss halt
Den Soundtrack von dem Game aus machen
Weil das ist
Das ist
Größeres Sound
Als
Cod 4
Ja
Das ist
Du spielst das Game teilweise nur nach Sound
Weil ich es natürlich sehr praktisch finde
Ich mag ja so Games wo man was hört
Und die Gegner orten kann
Wo man dann quasi dann um die Ecke stehen kann
Und dann mit der Shotgun piepen
Bam in your face
Ich weiß nicht
Fortnite ist nicht mein Fall
Ich mag Fortnite nicht
Mir gefällt das
Mir gefällt das Bau nicht
Und Puppke ist mir zu viel rumliegen
Ich bin ja allgemein kein Battle Royale Fan
Aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice hier
Das ist
Das macht Spaß
Allerdings neige ich in dem Game dazu
Mich übelst aufzuregen
Aber nachdem das Solo-Queue ist
Ähm
Trag ich mich da nur über mich selbst auf
Das ist dann halb so wild
Es kann aber sein
Dass ich
Stream-Klein-Rage quitte oder so
Äh übrigens
Armbrust ist
Dreckswaffe
Öh
Es hängt
Normalerweise springen hier 5
Mindestens 5 Gegner oder so ab
Und dann
Mal hören
Nix da
Gut
Nice
Sonst haben wir aber zumindest ein bisschen
Halbwegs brauchbare Waffen
Ähm
Das Game ist
Bisschen anders als die meisten
Anderen
Battle Royale Games
Die es so gibt
Man kann craften
An
Jeweils an der Schmiede
Und
Um zu craften braucht man Material
Das sind einmal diese Shards
Die man hier einsammelt
Und um seine
Um die beste Waffe zu craften
Für die
Wow
MonkaS
Was ist hier los?
Braucht man
Muss man Gegner killen
Das heißt wenn man keine Gegner killt
Kriegt man keine gescheite Waffe
Was ziemlich sackt
Ich hör was
Oder auch nicht
Das ist mein eigenes
Mein eigener Gaul
Oh nice
Besser als der Armbrust
Besser als die Armbrust auf jeden Fall
Ja und von
Von aufgehobener Rüstung und so
Kriegt man
Kriegt man halt Rüstung
Also zieht man ja unten
Ich hör hier was rumpacken
Also ist da was rot
Kannst hier nichts drauffallen
Okay
Die die Flanken jetzt
Flank
Flank Action
Vorholen wir uns noch mal ein paar Tränke
Hallo
Herrn Schatten
DesSeon
Achtung Flanken Reno
Jetzt
Wir haben sie gebashed
Oh Mages
Was hält denn der aus?
Ja
Wo ist das Hähnchen?
Wow
Okay
Jetzt können wir
Jetzt können wir was craften
Jetzt haben wir genug Material
Wir haben jetzt
Was haben wir?
Was haben wir denn?
Mögen wir hier
Was haben wir?
genug Material. Wo ist der
Typ hin? Unten ist er.
Rekt.
Get shrekt.
So, und jetzt müssen wir schnell was craften.
In der Hoffnung, hier ist keiner.
So, erstmal
Leckwaffe craften.
Armor Potion ist immer ganz gut.
Wow, wow, wow. Alter, alter.
MonkaS.
MonkaGiga.
Shrekt.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich hör noch was.
Alter. Ich brauch mal
eine Leckwaffe.
Na, fuck, alter.
Scheiße.
Ah.
Feels bad, man.
Intens.
Tja.
Kann ich alles gewinnen.
Ripperino.
In Pepperonis.
Das, ich mag halt bei dem Game, wie man eben auch
gesehen hat, der Fluss ist nicht so,
das ist nicht so lahm, wisst ihr? Also man,
man lootet nicht erst drei Stunden
und legt auch nicht drei Stunden rum
und man lootet halt
ein bisschen was, basht paar Gegner,
craft eine Waffe. Ihr habt's grad gesehen, ich hab halt
den einen Treffer gesetzt mit meinem
Legendary Granatwerfer, der andere halt
hat mich halt vorher schon, ich hatte ja vorher schon
Damage drin.
Das hat ja gleich mal 800 Damage gemacht. Hätte ich den nur ein, zwei Mal getroffen,
wäre der halt auch RIP gewesen.
Tja.
So, ich muss unbedingt
mein
Meme-Tool starten.
Jetzt müssen wir mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Und jetzt
im Fullscreen.
Ich glaub ja nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Glaub ich ja nicht. Probieren wir mal aus.
Ne, nicht so wirklich, ne?
Aber...
Ne, das klappt nicht. Suckt.
Okay, das muss ich danach fixen.
Das muss ich danach fixen.
Danach, danach,
ich stell danach um, Capture
Dings in Windows, in Window-Modus.
Moin.
Chris.
Es ist immer schwierig, Namen ohne Vokal auszusprechen.
Omega-Lull.
Ich stell danach in Window-Modus um
und dann kann ich wenigstens ein bisschen
ein paar Memes
wieder spammen.
Oh, oh, oh, zu hoch, zu hoch, zu hoch.
Lackt. Oh, wie das lackt. Habt ihr gesehen, wie das lackt?
Komm her.
Oh ne, Kackwaffe.
Besser.
Kommt man da hoch mit dem Rocket-Jump?
Hey, nice.
Siebtcher-Ping.
Ja, suckt.
Heal-Toter am besten.
Moment, hier ist einer.
Da blinkt er weg.
Wo ist denn der andere gewesen?
Irgendeiner hat mich hier grad abgeballert.
Schreckt, aber, aber...
Wo ist denn der?
Ich, ich sag gleich,
ich erzähl euch gleich was zu den Glassen, wenn ich
umgestellt hab. Wow!
Ah, der hat ne Kackwaffe.
Den, den auen wir jetzt.
Get schreckt.
Omega schreckt.
Moment, schießt der was auf mich gerade?
Oder bin ich einfach nur...
Bam, Alter, genau.
Hippos Lee.
Ach, da schießt wirklich was auf mich.
Fuck.
Wo war denn der jetzt?
Ah, da, da, da, ich seh's.
Achtung, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Omega-Fair-Trick.
Als seh ich dich nicht,
Alter.
Hörst du mich verarschen?
Wo ist er denn?
Immer schön durch die Bäume hüpfen bei sowas.
Das, diese, diese Waffen,
die sind so ganz merkwürdig, das
rumgelegge-Hitscan-ig.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ganz komisch.
Der hat jetzt getroffen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Hitscan, die Waffe, oder?
Das ist
Projektil, oder? Was sagt ihr?
Ist das Projektil?
Das ist ne Projektilwaffe, oder?
Hallo.
Ach, das ist kein Hitscan, deswegen fühlt sich das so komisch an.
Okay, ich muss craften gehen, Leute.
Ich muss unbedingt craften gehen.
Wir haben viel zu lang hier rumgehampelt.
Craft Reno müssen wir machen.
Weil ich hab genug Shards, ich hab mein Chicken-Bein.
Also mein Hähnchen, meine Hähnchenkeule.
Die man braucht zum Waffencraften.
The Fog sets in.
The Fog.
Foggers, Alter.
Foggers.
Ich hau mal meinen letzten Heal raus, dass ich auf jeden Fall an die Schmiede komm.
Oh!
Diese Projektilwaffe, das ist ganz merkwürdig hier zu aimen.
Okay, der Devil Fortune.
Soldiers of Fortune?
Ne.
Oh, jetzt fang ich an, dumm Zeug zu labern.
Oh, der hat Schnipper.
Schnipper.
Oh!
Weck ist Schneiber, die Sau, ey.
Fuck.
Das ist Unreal 3.
Auf welcher Engine das läuft, das ist Unreal 3.
Oh!
Kack.
Weck ist Schneibord.
Haller mich.
Genau, ich wollte ja umstellen jetzt auf Window Capture.
Nehmen wir das mal.
Ah, ah.
Remove.
Yes.
Zack.
Window Capt...
Nein, mein Visual Studio will ich nicht aufnehmen.
The Fog.
Moment.
Ach so, ich muss ja erstmal wieder das Ding umstellen in Borderless Window.
So, und nu.
Jetzt.
Ne.
Hä?
Kann man das nicht ordentlich capturen, oder was?
Was ist das hier?
Warum kann man das nicht capturen?
Window Capture?
Hä?
Okay, das Game kann man nicht capturen.
Das ist auch ganz toll.
Window Capture geht nicht.
Ja, dann müssen wir wieder umstellen.
Und Game Capture machen.
Dann kann ich, dann kann ich aber keine Memes einblenden.
Tja.
Ja, dann müssen wir mitleben.
So, Game Capture.
So, jetzt geht's, oder?
Seht ihr was?
Ja, na, jetzt soll's voll...
Ja, das ist doof.
Irgendwie kann man das Game nur Fullscreen capturen.
Sehr komisch.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Na gut, ich könnte, ich könnte Bildschirm Capture machen.
Ich mach einfach, ich mach danach einfach Bildschirm Capture und gut, ist.
Aber ich finde, wenn man hier landet, ist halt, wie man, wie man sieht, das ist am Anfang die übelste Action dafür, wenn du da rauskommst, hast du super Gear.
Du hast deine Leckwaffe, hast ordentlich, hast ordentlich Armor.
Äh...
Ah, Fullscreen.
Seht ihr was?
Ja, ne?
Müsste jetzt funktionieren.
Ja, also als Klassen gibt's hier einmal, ähm, das, was ich spiele, Engineer.
Da kannst du, kannst du Torb-mäßig, äh, Türmchen bauen.
Oder Barriers setzen.
Oder Rocketjumpen und sowas.
Das ist relativ Close-Quarter-lastig defensiv.
Dann hast du Warrior, das ist quasi Close-Quarter-lastig offensiv.
Da kriegst du als Legendary Weapon, äh, statt Granatwerfer, kriegst du halt so eine, so eine, so eine Wurf-Axt, die alles, alles ownt.
Irgend, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich brauch unbedingt, bevor ich, bevor ich jetzt mit den Zeitung hol, ich will mal auf jeden Fall ein bisschen tränke.
Ah, nice.
Alter.
Oh.
Weggekockt.
Ah, hier war noch was, oder?
Battle Royale Games mit Max.
Ja, das hätte ich selbst nicht für möglich gehalten, äh.
Meine, meine Fähigkeiten fehlen übrigens.
Wow.
Das war close.
Alter, der Typ fuckt mich ab.
Ups, hätte ich vielleicht aufheben sollen.
Hast du die Fußballspiele gesehen?
Nein.
Habe ich nix geguckt von.
Gar nichts Fußballmäßiges geguckt.
Ream, R, Omega, lol.
Ich hab meine Fähigkeiten nicht aufgehoben.
Wie der letzte Kack-Knub.
Ich brauch unbedingt Heiltränke.
Ohne Heiltränke ist jetzt Rip angesagt.
Kommen Videos zur E3?
Ne, die E3 ist noch fertig.
Koggers.
E3 ist noch fertig.
Ich hab doch zu jeder Pressekonferenz ein Stream gemacht.
Oh, nice.
Oh, die Dinger, die Pistolen sind so schlecht.
Die Pistolen sind so schlecht.
Oh, die sind so kacke.
Ich brauch, ich brauch Heal.
Ich brauch Heal, vielleicht gibt's hier noch was.
Problem ist ja, ohne, ohne, ohne Health kann ich jetzt hier schlecht rein.
Ist schon offen, ne?
Fuck.
Hier hinten ist auch schon auf.
Oh, nee.
Das ist jetzt, das ist, das ist, das ist Rip.
Ich seh schon, komm.
Ich glaub, hier war ich noch nie drin.
Hier ist auch alles offen.
Alles Crap.
Okay, wir, wir, wir, wir ownen den Typ jetzt an der Schmiede.
Wir ownen den Typ einfach an der Schmiede jetzt.
Easy.
GG, GG Eats.
Oh, Mann.
Das war, als ich zu wenig Leben hatte.
Scheiße.
Fuck.
Ach, was ein Scheiße, ey.
Ah, weggekockt.
Weggekockt.
Reverse weggekockt.
Ähm, vielleicht noch ein Meinungsvideo zu E3.
Ich glaub, da kann ich nicht allzu viel sagen, weil meine Meinung zur diesjährigen E3 war, das war stinklangweilig.
Das stinkt langweilig, also, Nintendo war für mich die Enttäuschung pur.
Leute, wollen wir uns, komm, wir gucken uns abschließend, wollen wir uns noch mal den, den Smash-Stream angucken?
Wollen wir uns noch mal, komm, komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal 20 Minuten Smash an.
Also, ich meine, da hätten sie eine Smash-Direct machen können, aber ich habe bei Nintendo drauf gewartet, dass sie mal was zum Online-Modus zeigen, zum Beispiel.
Also, irgendwas, was man noch nicht weiß.
Ich meine, das Einzige, was man zum Online-Modus weiß, ist, dass er irgendwann, wann startet er, im September, dass er, äh, wahrscheinlich was kostet und dass es irgendwie NES Classics oder irgendwie so ein Mist gibt.
Aber ich meine, ganz ehrlich, NES Classics, wer braucht denn NES Classics?
Ich denke, guck mal.
Im Zweifelsfall hast du das jetzt irgendwie schon vier oder fünf Mal gekauft, ein NES-Spiel.
Da hast du, da hast du das theoretisch, ähm, gekauft auf NES.
Dann hast du es irgendwie wie Virtual Console oder sowas gekauft.
Dann hast du es irgendwie wie U-Virtual Console gekauft, falls es, ne, das war was Eigenes, ne.
Dann hast du es irgendwie jetzt demnächst dann noch im Online-Modus, ey, das ist doch bescheuert, ich meine, NES-Games, ja.
Ja, es gab einen Nintendo-Stream.
Au, au.
Hier.
Der.
Schmeckt Bäschen neben mir.
Aber, kriegt er nicht hin, weil ich ihm die Waffen weggrabbe.
Fuck.
Verpiss dich, Alter.
Verpiss dich.
Achtung, Achtung.
Gebated, gebated.
Fuck.
Na!
Alter, was soll ich denn da machen?
Was soll ich denn da...
Was, was genau hätte ich da jetzt machen sollen?
Ich hätte wegreiten können wahrscheinlich, ey.
Ich habe gedacht, vielleicht ist es so doof und spannend.
Es springt mir irgendwie nach und ich kann ihn mit dem Schwert wegschwerten.
Ich kann mit dem Engineering nicht gescheit pushen, weil ich keinen Run-Speed habe.
Der ist schneller wie ich.
Also, das Hunter, der läuft zwar nicht schneller.
Es ist, dass er läuft schneller als ich, aber ein Hunter, der kann ja wegrollen und alles.
Ich habe eigentlich keine Chance.
Das Einzige, was ich machen könnte, ist versuchen, von oben irgendwie mit dem Rocket-Jump draufzuspringen.
Aber wenn er nicht ganz so bescheuert ist, dann regt er mich.
Aber das war jetzt dann auch sehr unglücklich, dass da keine Waffe drin war in der ersten Kiste.
Und dass ich übelst gesandwiched wurde.
Von beiden Seiten.
Suckt.
Die Map ist übrigens übelst unfertig, wie man hier sieht.
Hast du mal Path of Exile gespielt?
Ja, habe ich mit Fabian gespielt.
200 Stunden oder so.
Als es noch Beta war.
Ah.
Bestes Spot.
Wenn es so weitergeht, steige ich irgendwann wieder ab in Bronze oder so.
Bronze-Loop.
Und dann ist es so.
Plätschert.
Äh, Plätschert.
Oh, jetzt wird weggecrapped.
Wieder Master-Crab.
Jetzt wird weggecrapped und alles geowned.
Was?
Was war das denn?
War das kein Hit oder was?
Wollte ich verarschen?
Muss ich rollen oder was?
So, wo ist der Typ jetzt hin?
Wie jung bist du eigentlich?
Ich bin 33.
Wo ist der Typ hin?
Okay, da gibt es Tränke.
Tränke, beste.
Wichtigste.
Keine Fähigkeiten am Start.
Keine Rüstung.
Und gescheit.
Okay.
Bisschen was.
Immerhin.
Wir gehen jetzt mal andersrum.
Wir gehen jetzt nicht links hoch.
Wir gehen jetzt rechtsrum.
Die haben sich hier bestimmt schon alle verpisst.
Hast du nie nur Kuni 2 gespielt?
Nee.
Den ersten Teil fand ich geil.
Den zweiten Teil fände ich wahrscheinlich auch gut.
Habe ich auch nicht gespielt.
Oh, nice, nice.
Auch sehr nice.
Sehr schön.
Oh, jetzt läuft's.
Go on.
Sonst ist das richtige Skyrim-Pferd hier.
Guckt.
Kannst du auch 90 Grad-Bände hochreiten.
Okay, wo ist denn hier was?
Einfach schon mal die Hälfte der Leute tot.
Und ich habe noch nicht allen Gegner richtig gesehen.
Hier ist bestimmt alles gelootet drin.
Wow, da ist einer.
Moin.
Der ist da drin.
Alter, was?
Wo ist hier was?
Bin ich dumm?
Kaga.
Die sind nicht hitscaren-Waffen.
Das ist ganz grausam.
Okay, wir müssen uns verpissen.
The fog sets in.
The fog.
EU-Aim.
Wow.
Wo ist der Typ?
Ah, da hinten.
Ich seh dich.
Push, push, Reno machen wir jetzt.
Achtung.
Der hat nur Armbrust.
Kogas Armbrust.
Wo ist der Typ?
Boah.
Das war krass.
In your face, Alter.
Wo ist denn das Hähnchen hin?
Also, hier war ja noch ein Hähnchen.
Da musst du dich jetzt beeilen.
Das muss ich erwischen.
Oh, fuck.
Kogas.
Der Typ lebt schon wieder, der andere.
Wow.
Was?
Oh, Alter.
Ich muss mich pissen.
Und jetzt gehen wir da hoch und owen sie.
Oder auch nicht.
Ein bisschen Abstand halten.
Ich glaube, der hat seine Leck-Waffe.
Warte.
Oh, fuck.
Was ist hier los?
Ich muss meine Waffe holen.
Shit.
Die hat bestimmt schon jemand gelootet jetzt.
Nee.
Nice.
Da geht doch was, oder?
Da hat doch was geplitzt.
Wo ist der Hunter?
Huntors?
Verpiss dich.
Der flankt den jetzt.
Und dann werden sie, wenn wir sie beide wegfisten.
Ich sag's euch.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh, shit.
Shit.
Fuck, ich bin ein Kacknub.
Scheiße, ich bin so dumm.
Ich bin so dumm.
Warum bin ich denn nicht so...
Oh, wie dumm.
Oh, shit.
Ja, ich bin so dumm.
Naja.
Siehe.
Rank up.
Es geht aufwärts.
Ja, Blockwater.
Das Battlefield 5.
Also, ich finde die Frage allein schon übersichtlich.
Äh, ich finde die Frage allein schon überflüssig.
Klar, es ist Battlefield 5.
Ich meine, siehst du das nicht?
Ich meine, ich zeig dir das gleich mal.
Guck mal.
Ich zeig dir das gleich mal, woran man das erkennt.
Hier gibt's nämlich Armprothesen.
Das muss Battlefield...
Wow.
Was war das jetzt?
Ja, ich mag das Pacing von dem Game irgendwie.
Es ist permanent geht was.
Von Anfang an.
Wie gesagt, ich spiele da nicht sonderlich lang.
Ich glaube, in dem Game kannst du übelst auen.
Wenn du...
Wenn man ein bisschen eingespielt hat.
Also, die Schritte.
Hör dir die Schritte...
Das geht übelst ab.
Das Gear erinnert mich an WoW.
Ja, das ist ja auch...
Also, Paladins war ja schon...
Ich weiß, die Paladins-Fans wollen das nicht hören,
wenn man sagt, es war eine WoW-Kopie.
Eine Overwatch-Kopie.
Sagen wir mal, es war sehr inspiriert von Overwatch.
Und nachdem das hier ja im Endeffekt Paladins Battle Royale ist,
ist das halt auch sehr inspiriert von so ziemlich allem,
was es sonst so gibt.
Korgers.
Was?
What?
Die hat nicht mal einmal geschlagen.
The f...
What?
Okay, das war jetzt irgendein...
Was?
Was zum...
Okay.
Was war das denn jetzt, ey?
Ich dachte mal, okay, wenn die nichts macht,
du laufst mich zu und wir switchen halt zum Schwert.
Bam.
Ja, direkt.
Na gut, der Hersteller kann sich jetzt damit rausreden und sagen,
das ist ja Alpha.
Das ist doch Alpha, da ist das ja alles kein Ding.
Aber das ist einfach
ein historisch authentischer...
authentischer War Simulator.
Das sah das nämlich so aus.
Wahrscheinlich hat es einfach nur gelaggt, ja.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht, warum es laggen sollte, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber heute sind die Sauver eh.
Also an meiner Internetverbindung liegt es garantiert nicht.
Übrigens, ich habe gelesen auf Reddit,
dass man...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich heute Encoding-Optionen habe.
Ja, ich habe heute Encoding-Optionen.
Ich habe gelesen auf dem Twitch-Subreddit,
dass man auf Twitch jetzt bis zu...
bis zu 8 Mbit streamen kann.
Das muss ich dann mal ausprobieren, die Tage.
Weil 8 Mbit würde schon...
wäre ein Riesensprung von maximal 6 Mbit.
Das wäre ein Riesensprung.
Das würde einfach viel besser aussehen.
Oh, ne.
Omega-Lol.
Ich muss weg.
Piss dich, Alte.
Ups.
Das war ziemlich dumm jetzt.
Kommt man hier hoch?
Wobei, das habe ich schon ausprobiert,
ob man hier hochkommt.
Man kommt hoch.
Aber es ist schon gelootet.
Achtung, da ficken wir jetzt rein.
Äh.
Darf ich mal fragen, wo...
Wo genau geht hier was?
Ich habe so eine räudige Pistole.
Ah, da hinten geht was.
So richtig räudige Pistolen.
Die Pistolen sind in dem Game das Schlechteste, was es gibt.
Gefolgt von diesen komischen Revolvern.
Die sind ja auch übelst kacke.
Oh, da sind Tränke.
Ich brauche Tränke, Leute.
Ich brauche Tränke.
Unbedingt Tränke.
Wow, wurde ich gerade gehostet.
Ich kann gerade nicht...
Ich gucke, ich gucke gleich nach.
Ich habe nur den Hosting-Sound gehört.
Danke schon mal für den Host.
Ich sehe es gerade nicht.
Poggers, Alter.
Poggers.
Hier war einer.
Je nachdem, wie huge der Host ist,
muss ich jetzt nervös sein.
76.
Oh, krass.
Ich höre da was.
Ja.
Mal austauschen.
Keine Pistole da.
Oh, nice.
Mal salvagen den Krempe.
So, und jetzt schleichen wir uns...
Jetzt müssen wir noch was...
Ne, wir haben schon einen gekillt.
Okay, wunderbar.
Schleichen wir uns mal zur Schmiede.
Gucken, was da so abgeht.
War da links?
Da ist doch links was.
Der wird jetzt weggekockt.
Wir haben eine schöne Nahkampfwaffe.
Der wird jetzt...
Koggers wird da jetzt gemacht.
Wow.
The fuck?
Was ist hier los?
Gehen wir mal hier hoch.
Und hauen wir mal kurz ab.
Können wir ein paar Tränke abgreifen.
Okay, ich sehe jetzt gerade nicht so genau durch,
ehrlich gesagt.
Was hier...
Oh, oh, oh, da unten.
Was ist denn hier los, ey?
The fuck?
Okay, das mit Craft wird nix.
Und ich habe noch nicht mal ordentliche Rüstung.
Oh, das ist reudig.
Headshot.
Rekt.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, ich bin schiss, der hätte mich nicht erwischen können, ey.
Puh.
Oh, jetzt kann ich mal nachgucken.
Wer hat mich eigentlich gehorstet?
Ja.
Hi, Scorios hat mich gehorstet.
Danke für den Host.
Koggers.
Das war anstrengend, ey.
Da muss man sich ja auch...
Da muss man sich so viel konzentrieren bei dem Game.
Ich muss halt sagen, ne.
Ich habe jetzt mittlerweile...
Also, ich habe am Anfang mal Puppge ausprobiert.
Ich habe...
Dann mal ganz kurz fort.
Fortnite ausprobiert.
Fortnite ging mir übelst auf den Keks, weil man bauen muss.
Spielt einer von euch Fortnite?
Und...
Also, ich meine, das Bauen ist ja so das, was Fortnite hervorhebt.
So gegenüber anderen Games.
Was ich jetzt allerdings auch gelesen habe in der Fortnite-Community, ist das ein bisschen umstritten, ne.
Also, viele, die Fortnite spielen, sagen auch, ich habe auf das Bauen keinen Bock.
Wie ist das denn bei euch?
Bei den Fortnite...
Bei denen, die Fortnite...
Bei denen, die Fortnite spielen.
Also, ich habe bei vielen Leuten schon gelesen, sondern an sich finden sie Fortnite schon nicht schlecht, aber das Bauen nervt.
Ich meine, es kann halt auch nicht jeder in fünf Sekunden irgendwie den Turm hochziehen oder sowas.
Ja, und Puppge war mir ehrlich gesagt zu lahm und zu viel rumgeliege.
Ich habe das ja sogar damals gekauft, dass ich ein bisschen mit dem Erg spielen kann, aber das war irgendwie langweilig.
Warum spielst du kein Overwatch mehr?
Oh, das ist eine lange...
Das...
Weiß nicht, ob ich das fast jetzt aufmachen soll.
Ich habe es ja schon oft gesagt.
Also, das Hauptproblem, was ich mit Overwatch eigentlich habe, ist, dass das Rang zu wenig mit dem eigentlichen Spiel zu tun hat, wie es gedacht ist.
Oh, oh, hier wird es aber...
Oh, oh, hier wird es voll.
The fuck.
Oh, piss dich, Alter.
Okay, Achtung.
Hopp.
So, da werden wir jetzt mal was wegficken hier.
Was ist denn hier?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ist das hier irgendein Decoy oder sowas, ne?
Okay, wir verdrücken uns mal kurz.
Und holen wir ein paar Tränke.
Wann spielst du bei Paladins?
Gar nicht.
Oh, ich brauche Heal.
Helz.
Brauche ich Helz.
Ähm, wo war ich denn gerade bei Overwatch?
Ja.
Also, wie gesagt, das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass es so wenig in Rang mit dem zu tun hat, wie es eigentlich gedacht ist.
Wahrscheinlich war mein größtes Problem, dass ich das am Anfang ja mit einem festen Team gespielt habe.
Und wenn man eingespielt ist und man muss Rang spielen, ist das einfach so ein wahnsinniger Unterschied.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Moment, haben wir das nicht schon?
Und dann...
Dazu kommt...
Auch eine weitere Sache, die mich nervt, ist, dass die Patches und das alles irgendwie nur im Schne...
Leck.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum das gerade alles nicht richtig reingeht, weil es leckt wie Sau.
Dass alle möglichen Patches und Balanceänderungen...
Und hast du nicht gesehen, dass das in Overwatch im Schneckentempo passiert?
Ich brauche eine Rüstung.
Ordentliche Rüstung.
Nicht nur Rüstungstränke, sondern...
Sondern ordentliche Rüstung.
Äh.
Okay, jetzt ist beides kacke.
Oh, oh.
Ah.
Pff.
Wow.
Oh, über mir geht...
Geht die Party ab, ja.
Rekt.
Der lebt noch, der andere, oder?
Okay, holen wir mal erstmal das Chicken.
Wo ist es?
Wo ist das Chicken?
Psst.
Chicken.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ja, ich verschwende mal meinen einzigen Heal, weil ich muss den Scheiß irgendwie überleben.
Und jetzt müssen wir zur Schmiede, unbedingt.
Wir haben genug Shards, wir haben unser...
Unser...
Unseren Hähnchenschenkel.
Aber der Mage hüpft hier halt noch rum.
Mal gucken, wo der ist.
Wir looten jetzt hier noch, dann gehen wir direkt zur Schmiede.
Weil es wird ja langsamer Zeit.
13 Sekunden noch, bis die...
Bis die Foggers insettet.
Okay.
Ist eine Foggers.
Wonka Foggers.
Psst, psst, psst.
Naja, nix.
Okay, flanken wir mal rüber und gucken.
Naja, das war so nicht gedacht.
Wonka Giga.
Okay, es forcht.
Es forcht.
Gehen wir mal rechts rum.
Wir flanken jetzt...
Flanken jetzt mal rechts rum.
Und bashen die.
Wobei, uns fehlt so ziemlich alles, ne?
Uns fehlen die Waffen.
Uns fehlt alles.
Hat er seinen Schneiber?
Fuck, der hat seinen Schneiber aufgehoben, ne?
Siehste?
Scheiße.
Wir waren zu langsam an der Schmiede.
Ich glaube, die beste Variante wäre gewesen...
Ja, fuck.
...der einfach zu einer anderen gegangen wäre.
Wir hatten genug Material und alles.
Und wenn der seine Leckwaffe lootet, bringt es eigentlich überhaupt nichts,
wenn ich da irgendwie großartig Action mache mit dem.
Ja.
Ja, ich lese gerade im Chat, dass irgendwie...
...Overwatch-Balancing...
Ich habe...
Ich verfolge...
Also, ich gucke ja noch viel Overwatch-League.
Und in der Overwatch-League ist es ja wirklich gerade gar nicht so wild.
Also, ich meine, es wird zwar nicht jeder Held gespielt,
aber es ist ein bisschen mehr Vielfalt als im Ranked.
Zumindest haben wir so Master-Plus-Ranked.
Aber irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht.
Irgendwie macht Overwatch keinen Bock gerade.
Wenn das alles ein bisschen schneller gehen würde, dann vielleicht.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was du machen kannst,
wirklich, um Overwatch ordentlich zu balancen,
ist eben, es nicht zu balancen, sondern neue Helden rauszuhauen.
Also, mit nicht balancen meine ich halt, man sollte quasi nicht Patches releasen für Balancing,
also nur für Balancing, oder es daran ausrichten,
sondern einfach sagen, wir machen mehr Helden und machen Balancing,
ein bisschen so links und rechts.
Dadurch, dass es mehr Helden gibt, hast du halt auch viel mehr Variationen drin
und dann musst du den Kram nicht so viel balancen.
Da hast du halt viel mehr Optionen und viel mehr Varianten,
wie du spielen kannst.
Aber...
Das äh...
Ist denen wahrscheinlich ziemlich wurscht, wenn ich das erzähle.
Aber kann das sein, dass wir die letzten drei Runden übelst abgekackt sind?
Lustigerweise war aber permanent was los.
Ich kann übrigens auch nicht so lang.
Ich muss gleich noch mein Clary leveln.
Abend 18 Uhr...
spielen wir wieder Dungeons & Dragons.
...
Aber nicht on-Stream, ne?
Nur mal so, ja.
Aber Clary ist jetzt Level 4.
Und ich kann jetzt auswählen, ob ich welche Stats ich erhöhen will.
Mit Level 4.
Und falls sich da jemand von euch auskennt, sagt mir mal,
welche Stats soll ich denn erhöhen?
Also, ich hab natürlich alles, alles auf...
Alles auf Weisheit, ich mein, ich bin ja Clary, ne?
Und Weisheit, Con, Stärke.
Was lohnt sich denn jetzt davon am meisten,
über so einen Schwellenwert zu bringen?
War so, ja, D&D-Profis.
Also, ne, also quasi über 15, über 17 und so, was soll ich da...
Wahrscheinlich Weisheit als Clary, oder?
Und für alle anderen, die keinen blassen Schimmer haben, wovon ich rede, sorry.
Weil, ich kann euch das jetzt auch nicht besser erklären.
Ah, die Shotgun hätte ich nehmen können.
Nice, so.
Okay, Flank-Action, Flankerino.
Nicht hängen bleiben.
Die Kiste, habt ihr gesehen, wie die Kiste reingeleckt hat?
Wow, hinter mir.
Ich will jetzt den Typen aber noch wegkotten.
Oh, der hält ganz schön was aus.
Der will sich jetzt healsorten, ich sag's euch.
Was?
Nee, der ist abgehauen.
Hmm.
Lol.
NAA-Aim.
Mega NAA-Aim.
Wir flanken jetzt außen rum und dann werden wir von der Seite reinbashen.
Ich muss zur Schmiede, unbedingt.
Schmiede Reno.
Wa! NAA-Aim.
NAA-Aim.
Oh, da ist ein lila Spell.
Korgas.
Wo ist er denn?
Alter.
Okay, ich muss craften, Leute.
Ich muss unbedingt craften.
Scheißegal, ob ich hier was übersehen habe.
Das kriegen wir fertig.
Das kriegen wir fertig, bis der Fogg am Start ist.
Bis der Fogg aus...
Wa! No!
Fuck, ich hab nicht genug.
Ich hätt mehr Looter Reno machen müssen.
Ich loot jetzt.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich weiß ja, dass hier hinten noch Zeug liegt.
Ich hab schon alles looten müssen.
Was ein Slang, ja.
So ist es.
So, wenn wir schnell sind, können wir noch craften.
Foggars braucht 1 Minute 40, bis er da ist.
Und die Waffe braucht, glaube ich, eine Minute.
Und ich denke mal, hier ist keiner.
Weil das so direkt am Rand der Map liegt.
Fuck!
So, das wird ganz knapp.
Das wird ultra knapp.
Wenn ich krieg...
Ey, beiß ich mir in den Arsch.
Ich meine, es sollte passen.
Es sollte passen.
Da war was, oder?
Fuck. Fick dich.
Der muss jetzt kommen, der Typ.
Fick dich.
Wat?
Foggars. Foggars.
Alter!
Fick dich! Scheiße.
So wenig Tränke.
Ich brauch mehr Tränke.
Ich muss auch noch mehr Tränke craften.
Mit mehr Health wäre der gefickt gewesen.
War bestimmt Stream-Sniper, das lag nicht an mir.
Muss Stream-Sniper.
Oh, es geht aufwärts.
Wir sind jetzt schon Silber-Noob.
Ja, Sam Fisher.
Das kommt manchmal vor.
Manchmal überlebt man das als Chicken.
Ich glaube, am Anfang vom Stream haben wir es auch mal kurz überlebt.
Als sich da zwei Gegner gebasht haben, gegenseitig.
Aber das Game macht übelst Bock.
Das ist endlich mal ein Battle-Royale-Game, was ich gerne spiele.
Ich hab das ja mehr oder weniger erst, keine Ahnung,
drei, vier Stunden oder irgendwie...
Nee, ein bisschen länger schon.
Weiß nicht, ich hab letztes Wochenende mal ein paar Stunden gespielt.
Und heute.
Ich bin ja selbst noch ganz neu in dem Game.
Es hat Hacker? Ernsthaft?
Was denn für... Wie kommst du da drauf?
Was das für Hacker hat?
Und was für Hacks?
Also so die klassische Wallhack-Geschichte.
Oder irgendwie Minimap oder so.
Okay, haben wir schon.
Machen wir.
Also ich hab jetzt noch wenig gesehen an Cheater.
Aber wie gesagt, ich spiel auch noch nicht lang.
Holen wir uns hier unten nochmal was.
Das laggt übelst, ey.
Was ist denn heute mit den Servern los?
Ihr seht es ja teilweise auch,
dass man so rumwarpt.
Das Rumwarpen ist das Schlimmste.
Und was auch merkwürdig ist,
dass irgendwie glaube ich,
also der Unterschied zu letztes Wochenende,
wo ich es auch schon mal angespielt hab,
ich hab den Eindruck, hier haben manche Waffen
von Hitscan zu Projektil geändert.
Kommt mir so vor.
Was ist hier los?
Da haben übrigens noch kein Gegner gekillt.
Wir müssen was killen.
Oh was.
Wo ist er?
Fuck.
Da ist von rechts eine Mage angeflogen gekommen.
Der wartet doch jetzt da drin,
der will mich schnetzeln oder sowas.
Ah!
Ich hab da von hinten was gehört.
Sag mal, gibt es da irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
oben drauf zu kommen?
Oh, die battlen sich.
Da fickt man jetzt rein.
Ich hab das Chicken vergessen, ich brauch das Chicken.
Scheiß drauf, wir gehen zur Schmiede.
Schmiede ist keiner dran.
Wir haben nicht genug.
Wir haben nicht genug für Waffe.
Wir müssen noch was bashen.
Achtung.
Der wird jetzt geownt.
EU Aim.
EU Aimed wird er jetzt.
Hau da ab.
Wie der hier nur hergesprungen ist.
Ey, wollen die mich rollen?
Was ist das hier?
Der ist irgendwie so.
Was ist das?
Wir können nichts craften.
Wir haben zu wenig.
Aber diesmal habe ich nicht zu wenig.
Pots.
Foggers.
Wir brauchen die Waffe.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Das Wichtigste ist eigentlich die Leck-Waffe.
Damit kannst du dann nämlich auch Gegner
killen, die ein bisschen besser ausgerüstet sind.
Und dann kriegst du auch das bessere Gear.
Aber immerhin, wenn ich mir überlege,
wie übelst ich gesagt habe am Anfang.
So als Battle-Royale-Noob.
Und wie zumindest ein bisschen
weniger ich jetzt noch sacke. Ist ja schon mal was.
Wo geht denn hier was?
Oh, nice.
Legendary-Kiste.
Da kommen jetzt 20 Gegner hin.
Sehr nice.
Entschreckt.
Wir kommen dann zur anderen Schmiede.
Es fehlen jetzt halt noch
90...
Ne, wie viel braucht man? 70.
Irgendwie.
Craft-Material.
360 for the win.
Nur so geht das.
Ohne ist nicht möglich.
Suche Gegner.
Ich kann ja meine
Leck-Waffe nicht craften.
Gegner.
Keine Gegner da.
Wir gucken mal, ob da Kisten drin sind.
Weil wir haben immer noch kein richtiges Gear.
Kein ordentliches.
Hier waren auf jeden Fall Kisten drin.
Reiten wir mal zur Kiste.
Irgendwo müssen ja mal Gegner sein.
Der Foggas kommt.
Ja, Thotham ist richtig nice.
Das stimmt.
Thotham ist übelst nice.
Heal Thotham.
Was irgendwie nicht umsonst so...
Ich finde, es sieht aus wie ein WoW-Schamanen-
Thotham irgendwie.
Gegner.
Gibt es nicht.
Overrated, cheap baited. Keine Gegner.
Ich höre auch nichts.
Also es ballert auch keiner rum.
Gegner.
Nichts da. Keine Gegner.
Ich meine, das einzige Gute, was wir haben,
ist eine gute Waffe.
Restliches Gear ist Müll.
Wir können auch nichts craften.
Wow.
Der wird jetzt geornt.
Wat?
Ohne.
Ich salvage dich nur.
Wobei, eigentlich ist es bescheuert.
Ich salvage den Scheiß lieber.
Geh in die Schmiede und mach mir mal was Gescheites.
Moment.
Wat?
Wo ist denn die Schmiede hier?
Ist die nicht hier?
Ah ne, da drüben.
Lol.
Oh oh, da kommt was.
Scheiße, ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Fuck. Wie kann man es eigentlich so sehr verkacken?
Ich hab sogar noch den Schatten von dem Typ gesehen.
Ey.
Alter, wie dumm ey.
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Ich ragequitte jetzt.